Democratic presidential hopeful
delighted he's with us Andrew yang
thinks he has the answer and joins me
now Andrew first of all thank you very
much for being on with us tonight we
really appreciate it
Seattle is one of the most beautiful
cities in the country it just is I mean
San Francisco Seattle San Diego the
spectacular places what can be done
that's not being done now in this
beautiful city given the leadership
that's in place and given the enormity
of the problems well the cost of living
in Seattle in San Francisco both of them
of skyrocketed over the last number of
months and so my plan would put $1,000 a
month into the hands of every American
adult and that would create an economic
incentive for cities to be able to
invest in people who are struggling with
substance abuse or homelessness and
hopefully get the economic resource and
place to provide them a path forward and
in some cases even access to shelter and
housing so you think a thousand bucks a
month it's gonna make much of a
difference here because it seems like
we're way beyond that I mean I remember
Gavin Newsom when he was mayor of San
Francisco or on the city council City
Council he actually came in it was a day
I started my radio show his back in gosh
was back in 2001 and April he came in
and he said giving cash to the homeless
was a disaster so Gavin who said that we
did we did card so we gave them cards
for extra food I think and shelter maybe
but they found the cash payments didn't
work at all in fact it just incentivized
people to be more or less industrious I
would say and and that's Rob in Andrew
just just on the money according to Cato
I guess it was since the war on poverty
was declared what was at 1964 we've
spent about 23 trillion dollars so
didn't seem to help us at least in the
cities well the question is where did
that money go Laura and my plan would
put economic resources directly into our
hands and it would create again an
economic path for it for many people who
right now are struggling and don't have
access to it's let's say treatment force
it's abuse problems or mental health
issues because right now we have to face
facts
where these problems are growing in many
of our cities and our current programs
are not well designed to handle this
particular problem because in large part
if there's someone who's lying on the
street there's not right now an economic
incentive to help that person get back
on their feet
give a thousand bucks to a guy on the
street not everybody some people are
just down on their luck but there is a
significant percentage of people and we
know from just two blocks from where we
are now there's a homeless shelter a lot
of people have a lot of problems their
drug problems there's mental health
issues so giving a thousand bucks to a
person who already has a mental health
problem it's probably not gonna do the
job
that doesn't mean that's probably that
money's probably gonna go be quickly be
spent on things that are gonna get that
individual into more problems that's I
think the concern of just giving cash to
people because they're obviously not
making good decisions many of them to
get into the position they're in already
in a very expensive City but I want to
read you a statement hold on Android
that you made just a few weeks ago to
Newsweek you said when I've talked to
trump voters around the country they've
said that they're disappointed and what
they've gotten from the administration
they feel like a lot of it was bluster
in hot air but recent goldman sachs
study found that wage growth has picked
up sharply bottom 50% of wage earners
are making more consumer confidence is
up got other metrics up at 71% have
since the beginning of pulling on
confidence in the economy things people
think they're gonna get things they can
get better so this idea that nothing's
working with Trump I just think that's
an overstatement at best well I've been
around the country now and a lot of
people don't feel like they're connected
to a lot of the statistics that are
coming out and if you remember Donald
Trump the candidate in 2015 he said that
a lot of these headline unemployment
numbers were misleading and they don't
report what's happening on the ground
and then now that he's in the White
House he's singing a very different tune
the experience I'm having when I talk to
voters around the country is that 78% of
them are living paycheck to paycheck
57% can't afford an unexpected $500 bill
I think you're right about that there a
lot
a lot of people who still are vulnerable
they're still feeling insecure but this
is this has been going on for what 20
years they've had flatlining income for
18 years preceding Trump finally it's
going up but there's back to leadership
though and err because I think you're
someone I don't maybe agree with you but
you're someone who seems like you want
to solve things you want you want to
solve problems and I respect that Forbes
says the top five cities in the United
States with the largest homeless
populations are the following it's not
surprising so New York LA Seattle San
Diego San Jose now four of five of these
cities are run by Democrats so how is
liberal governance working out for these
cities my hometown of Hartford outside
of Hartford Connecticut about Hartford
Connecticut it's it's it's having real
problems had problems for a long time
always Liberal leadership and hard for
Detroit Chicago has big challenges it's
not like these are raging conservative
districts of the country Andrea now
that's one reason why we need to build a
trickle up economy that works for
everyone by putting economic resources
directly into people's hands because
we're in the midst of this
winner-take-all economy you can
certainly see it in our urban areas
where there are rich and poor living
next to each other in very different
circumstances and unfortunately the
dynamics of our economy are just going
to become even more extremely polarized
as technology starts transforming
industries like retail transportation
food service and on and on so we need to
wake up to the fact that we're in the
midst of the greatest economic
transformation in our country's history
and start moving in a direction of just
putting economic resources directly into
our hands because we're the only problem
did anyone give you a handout to start
or work with Matt Manhattan prep you
started that right was that your baby
now well that was my baby and we've all
had hand in and yeah you did really well
you were really I mean you're really
good successful entrepreneur and you've
got you work really hard when everyone
gets help but did anyone hand you a
thousand bucks to get you got I mean
well a lot of people including
entrepreneurs have something in the way
in other words you're a successful
capitalist and there's nothing wrong
with that I mean you've you've you've
become a huge success because of the
market and because of your hard work
and because of your work ethic all of
that together your family I imagine not
everybody has a family who supports them
but that all that combined to really
work for you well and that's a great
thing about putting these economic
resources into our hands is I'll give
more people an opportunity to start
businesses you would create 2 million
new jobs in the economy it would reward
hard work because right now many
Americans might have a great idea but
they're stuck with their heads down and
they're not able to build around them
and build a new business I co III
maintain this the best time in my
lifetime to be an American if you want
to work and you want a job it's it's
only it's all the sky is the limit right
now I think but Andrew we really
appreciate your joining us tonight
it's really interesting conversation